ground reaction force data joint
kinematics
underfoot pressure thermal cameras high
speed video the bridge between data and
performance is really that with the
right information we can make better
decisions
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm keith stern and i use data to
help athletes break records
at the top level runners there's only a
few seconds between the person that
finishes first and the person that
doesn't podium finish at all so any
small change can really make a big
impact down the road
my job here is to work with the rest of
the reebok innovation team to help bring
data into the design process
hi my name is dan hobson i'm the vp of
innovation there's a lot of information
to take into consideration on campus
here we built a crossfit box and lived
with the athletes monitoring how they
were working out what they were eating
how they were recovering and making that
understandable for the design team keith
stern is testing the product he's
gathering data the amount of data he can
compile with his team is vast
a lot of our testing on athletes starts
here in the human performance
engineering lab the force plate
treadmill is actually a split belt
treadmill so that we can record horses
from the left and right foot
[Music]
our mechanical impacting machine
simulates what we see in ground reaction
force data and then look at the
performance of material over time
through high-speed video we can track
how much your foot is moving in certain
areas a lot of times we can't see with
the naked eye what's going on in those
really fast movements so slowing it down
that transfer of knowledge is way easier
than graphs and charts and numbers
it's really easy to understand how the
shoe works with that person can make a
big difference in their running form
future of data collection and athletic
performance is something that's really
important there's a growing field of
smart sensors sensors could be woven
into this technology that we're
developing with flexweave
flexweave is really a method of weaving
materials together and allows us to
combine structure durability into a
single package that's also still
lightweight and breathable the same
types of things that we record in the
lab we could then record on foot in the
field so if you have those smart fibers
in the flex weave if you want to track
heart rate or distance or put gps in it
you know into those fibers you can weave
that into the fabric
the more data we have the better we can
make decisions on what types of material
advances are actually making an
improvement
providing that performance benefit even
if it's just comfort to get people up
and active that's what's really
important to me
[Music]